6 13 on your thursday morning welcome
back we all know the scale
the strat fundraiser been around for
quite a while people running up 108
flights of stairs
raising money for the nevada chapter of
the american lung association and a
shout out to the strat for all their
years of support but things are changing
because of the pandemic so it's going to
be at a different location this year and
it's coming up a week from
saturday march 6th joining us now to
talk more about it we have shannon
proctor the executive director of the
nevada american lung association hey
shannon thanks for getting up early with
us this morning
thanks for having me mate good to see
you so we know the event has
scale the strat and again shout out to
the strat for all their years of support
it's just too confined in there so
moving it to the las vegas ballpark this
year
that's right uh nate and you know i want
to give a big shout out and a thank you
to our presenting sponsor for since this
event's inception
anthem blue cross blue shield nevada
when the american lung association
decided to move all of their fight for
air climbs outdoors
because of the pandemic anthem really
stepped in to help us find a
stadium where we can climb outside
safely and las vegas ballpark came on
as our host this year we love the strat
we hope to return but we're looking
forward to a stadium climb this year
so folks kind of scratch their heads a
little bit shannon they go steps at the
ballpark yeah obviously they have some
i'm guessing you guys have counted the
number of stairs
out at the ballpark uh we have we have
and this year
it's going to be a little bit different
if you've scaled the strat we're going
to be up going
up and down stairs so we're going to
kind of snake through the lower bowl
of the las vegas ballpark and for those
who like to count nate yeah it's about
650 stairs okay so
we know that the climb is your
organization's biggest fundraising event
where does the money go that you raise
from these things
nate our mission is to fight lung
disease so we do that by
you know programming and services here
in in the valley uh making sure that
we're funding research and and they
we're currently the american lung
association funding our covet 19 action
initiative
this is a 25 million dollar investment
to address
covid and to protect all of us from
future respiratory pandemics
so we're saving lives and we're fighting
for lung health
and the thing is about registering for
the event boy i looked at the website
there's already people raising a ton of
money
how do you register either in person or
virtually
well this year we are not taking
in-person registrations because of covet
and safety we want everyone to
pre-register online
so to you go to fightforairclimb.org
las vegas and register uh there's a
thirty five dollar registration fee and
we do
uh have a hundred dollar mandatory
fundraising minimum
really easy to reach once you register
but we'd love to have you all come out
so register
um we're taking registrations until
march 4th at about noon
okay so we still have a week or so to go
and uh channel eight in the past has had
teams
brian loftus and one of our assignment
desk guys
jonathan sasowski we've talked about
getting together for climbing this year
i definitely want to be there because
what an experience and what a way to
raise money shannon
oh nate we would love to have you guys
come out and take tackle the stairs at
the las vegas ball park with us
it would be amazing to have you we look
forward to seeing you guys and the other
thing is shannon uh
while we do have the official name of
the event as climb for air
you can still get there when you do
scale the strata it'll still get you
there
good to know yeah okay so shan real
quick before we go
i have done scale the strap myself for a
few years and we have a photograph of
what it's like
once you finish now most people are in
jogging outfits or sweatpants
i have on purpose just worn a flannel
jacket and work pants because
i want to show folks shannon that it's
possible for any person
to do this event and we're not really
timing ourselves it makes it basically a
fundraiser to
help the american lung association in
nevada right that's right they i mean
you do it in style that's for sure
um we do you know give you your
finishing time if you are interested in
knowing how well you did
but it's really about the cause and it's
really just coming out um
and having a good time and raising money
you know to fight lung disease
awesome shannon thanks so much for
getting up early with us this morning we
will see you a week from saturday
and again you can go to our website for
details or do scale the strat or climb
for air
shannon thanks again you guys have a
great day out there thanks nate i hope
to see you on march